wow and uh besides we might be seeing  them two gold medalists who went on  undefeated yeah because you said that  the uzbek team was the one who was  undefeated and the ukraine team was  undefeated  uh  yes i mean this is what you were  quizzing me yes  absolutely  yeah that's it king d7 played it's the  last move  and guarantees gold medal for the yeah  why why are they not mobbing him i guess  they actually kicked everybody else out  because they would be mobbing him  absolutely right now of course  yeah  oh my god congratulations yeah yeah huge  congratulations to uh to the uzbekistan  team unbelievably played olympia there  you see smythes there in in the  background  uh obviously hugely disappointed by by  the fact that they're losing today but  i mean credible result by by the  netherlands anyway and yeah there you  see them  fantastic